we've been texting she's doing great
Chrissy Teigen shares an update on Kim
Kardashian's road to recovery after
being robbed at gunpoint in Paris I have
no idea what my life would be like after
I can't even fathom it so no I'm just
I'm just proud that she's back at home
and able to be other babies while Kim
went on a nun following spree on Twitter
after her traumatizing experience we
don't expect Christie to go completely
silent on social media but she has taken
steps to filter out hateful comments by
making her account private it's actually
life-changing honestly it's a it's
really wonderful when i check my
mentions to be able to see a positivity
in love and everyone says why don't you
just make it so you know you only see
mentions from those that you follow but
i really liked seeing my fans I really
like interacting to them so for me it
was really important to even private now
but still see what they have to say I
look the model is also enjoying the joys
of motherhood ET show the new mom a pic
of her daughter Luna and she gushed
about Lou's recent milestone that
involves her own guilty pleasure oh
maybe blue she just turned six months
yesterday she had her first bites of
like a baby cereal it was so excited for
obviously I love food I could not wait
to cook for her but to be able to put
something on a spoon and like just
so is everything